helena today's portrait is of francoise
barry sinuses
a french virologist who received a nobel
prize
for her work on hiv
what is the story behind the portrait
you know when she was a young scientist
male scientist told her it should be
better
to stay at home and take care of her
children
but she said she refused this kind of
things
and also she was very dedicated to her
research
and a wonderful story you know uh when
the wedding day came
she went to the lab to do a little bit
research and then suddenly her husband
called you know we are here waiting with
all the people
where are you now today is our wedding
that oh
i forgot it because i i thought the time
is running and i didn't
see it and so immediately she she went
to her own wedding
and you know in 1983 she discovered that
the hr virus was the reason for the
disease
but still it took a long time to find a
treatment for it
and she got the nobel prize for her
research
but still she is very modest that you
know i'm a puzzle
because many scientists contributed also
to the research
now she is retired and the lab is closed
and that's the reason in france always
when you're retired
and she's still working as an ngo in
several countries